[wind rumbling]
OK, so Bobby,
where we're heading
is 100 foot drop off that lip.
We're right on the edge of
this, like, boulder, slab
of rock that just curls away.
And it's one of
these awkward ones,
because you can't
see over the lip.
We're going to go across
and try and secure ourselves
and then figure out a way down.
Let's follow this moss, OK?
All right.
It's getting steeper, and
it's actually a drop-off,
meaning if I were to take
two steps this way and slide,
I would fall off the edge of it.
It's super slick and scary.
BEAR GRYLLS: So
we're probably going
to need the rope for this.
Have you got that--
have you got that claw?
I don't know what that is.
BEAR GRYLLS: Did you get that?
We're going to use these bear
claws-- they're called talons--
and dig it into the moss.
The moss is only about
that deep, though, so this
is a little bit sketchy.
So if you stand on those--
BOBBY BONES: That moss
will hold those claws?
Well, that
probably would hold.
BOBBY BONES: Probably work.
Yeah.
I'm a little nervous
about this one.
I'm not going to lie to you.
BEAR GRYLLS: OK.
Let's get this rope sorted.
I think this is definitely
a baptism by fire--
or rather rain and wind--
for Bobby.
These sort of things,
in perfect conditions,
are all really manageable,
but everything becomes harder
when you can't feel
your fingers and you're
cold and wet through.
Put your weight in it, Bobby.
Put your weight, because I need
your counterbalance on this.
That's it.
Keep going.
Keep coming.
Keep your weight on it.
BOBBY BONES: OK.
Lean back?
BEAR GRYLLS: Yeah.
All good.
Now, those talons are
actually holding well.
[dramatic music]
Look at that.
There's long water
slide off to your head.
BOBBY BONES: Oh, my god.
BEAR GRYLLS: OK.
Here we go.
Well done.
Keep walking down.
Walk it down.
That's it.
BOBBY BONES: Oh, god.
Keep it going.
BEAR GRYLLS: Almost there.
Good, Bobby.
Good.
BOBBY BONES: Whoo!
BEAR GRYLLS: Good job.
OK.
And that talon held.
Looking back, it was
definitely a smart decision
to use the rope on this.
So from here, we're pushing on.
And what I can see
is it is boggy.
Norway.
Bogs.